john chappelle asking
how do you get booked on colleges when
you are ready
great question john and a lot of my
colleges have been booked via
word of mouth most of them have been
booked from other comics i know
i can tell you in my 10 years of
experience most of my biggest
opportunities and most of the comics are
interviewed which is over 300 now most
of their
opportunities have come from other
comedians they haven't come from a
manner they haven't come from an agent
they've come from either a fellow comic
or them being funny at a show and
someone in the audience wanting to book
them
on something so in my experience i don't
have a college agent but there are
college agents just like there are
cruise ships agents and there are
um corporate agents and tour agents and
things like that
so there are agents within the comedy
game that you can
connect with and they can book you on
things there's also organizations called
naca and apka that you
can apply for you pay to get in but
honestly like
if you can get in with colleges um it'll
it'll you'll it's a it's a great
investment if you can get in with
colleges and get booked
um but when you are ready is the key
with colleges
john because a lot of how colleges work
it's the re-book
and one of the interviews i did with
ronnie jordan who is
one of i think he set the record for
doing the most colleges in a single
uh year like he is one of the most
highly demanded
college acts in the game and one of the
funniest peop like period funniest
people i would put him up against anyone
as one of the funniest people
that i know and i've seen uh is
incredible that i mean he can perform
anywhere but he
kills it at colleges and he actually has
people that used to watch him in college
now come to his shows at the clubs and
stuff so that's cool he's been able to
build a fan base
but he kills it at colleges and he said
the number one thing with colleges is
that rebook
is getting ass back so you want to make
sure you're ready because colleges have
specific expectations for you some
colleges
you can't swear or some colleges you
can't talk about these
topics and there's a contract that you
sign to do that some colleges
they want you to do 30 minutes some
colleges want you to do 60 minutes
and when they say 60 they mean 60. they
don't mean
58. like i've heard some experiences of
comics
who maybe got up a little bit early and
they didn't get paid
because their contracts had 60 and they
didn't fulfill that
and there's a these are networks of
colleges
so if you don't do well at one or if
you're unprofessional
that word spreads throughout other
colleges and that's where that rebook
comes in so if you're not ready and you
get booked on one college
that may be your last college so there's
a few routes you can go
joining apko joining naca getting a
college agent
or they just kind of come to you
as your as you're ready i mean a lot of
these experiences in your career are
going to come
when you're ready for them so it's
focusing on being patient
and focusing on the crap and just
getting as funny as possible
so keep that in mind when you're trying
to pursue
something like a college gig there is no
right way there's only your way
but you can get some you can build a
team around it with agencies and things
like that
but it's also like um so whenever i've
got booked on a college from a friend
i make sure to follow up with them hey
any other colleges
that we could work on together or if
there's like
if their agent booked them on there and
they brought me along
if i meet their agent i'm sure to
introduce myself and
get their information and be accessible
to them if they need anything as well
so it's just first off being ready and
then being accessible and being
professional that's half of this game
in comedy is just being professional so
people want to work with you
because you can only make one first
impression you want to make sure that's
not your last
impression but your first impression is
your lasting
impression oh that's not a bad
not a bad quote there so
yeah there's a bunch of different ways
to get booked on colleges there's a few
my personal experience has come from
just
being in comedy long enough to have
friends that do colleges and that need
openers but when you're when you're
ready
is best but when you're ready they do
pay well uh corporate corporate pays
well as well
um so there's all different types of
ways to pursue this comedy game
some comics make a full-time living just
on colleges
that's it they all they do is perform at
colleges and they make six figures and
they're killing it
so there's there's no one path in this
game
it's just kind of what you want to get
out of it if you want to start doing
colleges start
being intentional about you seeing a
comic doing colleges
that you know or that you could reach
out to reach out to the comic you know
comics like to help each other that's
what we're all about here in
hot breath is a supportive community of
comics
you know working together to become the
next generation of great comics
so if you see a comic we usually like to
help each other reach out to them dm
them tweet them
and ask them some questions about you
know
how did you get on colleges how would
you recommend me doing it type deal
and maybe they may even take you on a
gig with them you just never know
good question john hey hop brother and
sister and if you enjoyed this comedy
tip
subscribe to this youtube channel and go
join
our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a